I have a voicemail number that number is
two one nine to david p you can call any
time of day here's a voicemail i
received yesterday come back alright so
the constant theme of your show is uh
blacks are powerless they uh you know
can't get anything done themselves they
need uh you know a big white brother
help them out and you know you give the
benefits yeah but whatever like occur to
you that it might be racist to have this
line of thought that blacks are
powerless you know they can't get
anything done themselves we can stop at
there and uh think this is alluding to
this idea of the subtle racism of low
expectations and what the caller is
saying is by arguing that black people
need to be helped to achieve anything am
I not arguing that they just have
absolutely no power or agency your way
to help themselves this is what we call
a straw man argument this is attacking
me prefer a position I have never taken
and I hate to break it to you but
pointing out that certain laws are
applied disproportionately by
institutions of power for example or
that there are historic racial
inequalities which still are noticeable
today in some ways that we need to
account for that is not arguing that
black people or all brown people are
powerless to help themselves Jason is
getting schooled very quickly here on
what we call straw man arguments calling
in and they're very very powerfully
critiquing david pakman for something he
never actually said yeah i was / thing
at first thought i had there was did you
actually even say that no clearly on the
right thought if that's the first
thought you're having then you're
absolutely on the right path as far as
that goes so yeah i'm not going to
defend that position because it's not a
position i've ever taken on the bonus
show today we now have seen the success
of the first child to receive a double
hand transplant he is now writing and
making lunch for himself we will also
continue our discussion of driverless
taxis which now all
so exist in Singapore is it similar to
pick Pittsburgh to hail a driverless
taxi uh ins in singapore and pittsburgh
or is it different we will also follow
up on some of your ideas about the
future of the bonus show of course you
can sign up for instant access to the
world-famous bonus show at david
pakman.com slash membership